-Our next guest is an
Emmy Award-winning writer
for her work on "Saturday Night
Live" and an actress you know
from "A.P. Bio,"
"Sisters," and "Girls5eva."
The first two seasons are
streaming on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Why didn't Girls5eva get
the opener gig?
-Sorry, we're in the middle --
-Sexism, ageism?
Which ism ism-it?
-Cozy Boy was just a better fit.
-How? People walked out.
-I'm sorry, but this just isn't
the right time, okay?
Can we just get a little B-roll
of me and the wallpaper?
-I'm not leaving.
-Come on.
-Look, the one with the beard,
we deserve the truth.
And I'm willing to fight you
for it.
-Are -- Are you kidding?
-Do it, bitch.
♪♪
Come on!
-Dear God.
-Who is that?
-Come on. Come at me!
-Do you yield?
-[Bleep] modern Jesus.
[Bleep]
-Please welcome back to the show
the best in the biz,
the one, the only Paula Pell!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Ah!
So life-affirming to be here.
Hello, everyone.
-Thank you for affirming all of
us, and we're so excited
that season three of "Girls5eva"
is moving over to Netflix.
-To Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're about to start shooting.
-Yeah, we're shooting
in a few weeks.
We're starting to shoot, and
we're going on tour because
at the end of last season, we
decided to pay for our own tour.
So it's going to be real janky,
which is good for comedy.
So Sara and Renee and Busy and I
will be reunited.
And I'm so excited because I
have so much fun on that show,
and it's such a fantasy to be
able to sing with them
and out-sing them.
Let's be honest.
-Yeah, you're the best.
Of all of them, you're the best.
You know, you're living a lot of
your best life right now.
You have a big birthday
coming up April 15th.
This is a big one.
-Tax day.
-Yeah.
-People are not distracted
at all on the day
that my birthday is.
Um, I am turning 60.
-Congratulations. Big one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was going to say sexty,
but I'll probably say a lot of
things like that.
I've never been -- As you know,
I was born at 50, and I am
a matron, and I did all the
old-lady parts in theater.
And I just was always
the old lady.
So I always used to lecture
anyone that was going like,
"Oh, my God, I'm going to
be 40,"
and I'd be like,
"Numbers mean nothing."
And now I'm completely losing my
mind about 60 because it just
feels -- it does feel like
you're on the other end,
kind of fading in the boat,
going...
[ Laughter ]
"You guys have a wonderful
life."
[ Laughter ]
-But you have a really nice
life.
-But I have such an incredible
life now.
I moved from L.A. to the woods
of upstate New York,
a little bit upstate, and we
live among all these crazy
animals that are wild, and then
we have a crap-ton of animals,
and emphasis on "crap."
I have two old horses and I have
five dogs and two cats.
-Here's a photo of your five
dogs, who are very nicely posed.
-Those are our pack.
-Good pack.
-And these two are new,
and we lost a -- our little
alpha Chihuahua,
who ran the household,
at Christmas.
So, of course,
I'm like devastated.
Janine's devastated, my wife,
and we're just like,
"We can't even bear it --"
and everything.
And then at night, like porn,
I'm looking on Petfinder,
and I'm like, "What about these
two 16-year-olds?"
[ Laughter ]
Because my dream is to, like,
adopt very old dogs.
We've always done it,
and then you think it's going to
be like -- you think it's going
to be like Aunt Queenie
that's going to live there
until she dies in six weeks,
and then Aunt Queenie lives
there for 10 years.
[ Laughter ]
-So you think a dog has sort of
a whole second wind?
-Oh, my God. You give them
a happy life, and they're just
like, "Hunker down because I
ain't dying."
[ Laughter ]
And so we got those,
and sometimes I'll look
and be like, "Janine, this one
has already passed.
Should we adopt this one?"
[ Laughter ]
But we have -- we've created
this, like, dream life
of having all these animals.
-This looks like --
tell me if I'm wrong --
but what am I looking at here?
This looks like a dog bed
but big enough for a person.
-So, this is my friend Michelle.
This is something I wanted to
purchase for my 60th.
I saw it on "Shark Tank."
It's a human-size dog bed.
[ Laughter ]
And this beagle/basset,
William the beagle/basset,
he is very -- he's losing
his back legs really bad.
So he can't get up on anything,
and he looks at all of us up
there cuddling, and he's just,
like, longing.
So I wanted something where I
could actually spoon him.
There's nothing going on.
Calm down, Republicans.
[ Laughter ]
But we have this -- we have this
incredible bed now,
and Michelle is actually
one of two women
that are living with us
now in our guesthouse.
They're a vet and a vet tech,
Lainey and Michelle.
So I am living the lesbian
high-society dream.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
And so we'll call them,
and we'll be like,
"Do you want to come over
for tacos? Janine's cooking."
And then I'll be making dirty
martinis while they're
expressing my dog's anal glands
in the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- Oh, hi, Fred.
-[ Laughing ]
Is everything okay with --
-Yep.
I didn't know -- I didn't
know, and it's okay.
[ Laughter ]
Where were we?
-Wait. Don't you have a new name
for your compound?
-Yes. My brilliant wife,
who is a comedy writer as well,
named it Breastchester.
[ Laughter ]
So we have sweatshirts that say
Breastchester,
and it's just amazing.
It's really good.
-I can't help but note you
recently sustained an injury.
Is that what's happening there?
-Yes, I -- Yes. Hello.
[ Laughter ]
NBC can't do anything about it
because it's just an injury
I'm talking about.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, Fred.
[ Laughter ]
No. I slammed -- Just when I was
starting to dig myself
out of the depression of being
60, I did a RuPaul death drop
on the ice last week,
like really death drop
with my leg bent behind me.
And then two days later,
I went to a restaurant
and slammed my finger
in the bathroom door.
And it is like the color of
Sherwin-Williams,
like, "mob hit under the dock"
black.
And it looks like
a burnt hot dog.
But I happen to have a bunch of
old condoms
from the '80s in my jewelry box.
And so I have one over it,
little --
-Why do you have those?
-Because for about a year
after my first girlfriend,
I was very brokenhearted,
and I went down penis avenue.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Just for one year?
-Just for one year.
-Okay.
-Not continuous.
I mean, I took breaks and stuff.
[ Laughter ]
I figured it out. And I --
It's such a vivid memory.
I mean, not enough to tip
the scales.
[ Laughter ]
But it's such a vivid memory
that I think that
I could draw one.
-Okay.
-You know what I mean.
By memory. I'm going to do it.
-So this is -- this is -- this
is from the '80s, Paula?
-This is from the '80s.
-So you're going from your brief
jaunt down penis avenue
in the '80s.
You're going to draw from
memory.
-I'm just going to really think
of, like,
da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Probably have to pay for that.
-It helps to sing a song
from the '80s?
-Well, from the '80s, yeah.
-Gotcha.
-I remember the top of it.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-The top was kind of round.
-Okay. This is great.
And this is not --
None of this is making you
long for it, right?
-No, and it's not anyone's
specifically.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Fred.
[ Applause, woman cheers ]
-And you feel confident
this is what they still
look like on human men?
-Yeah, this is definitely
what it still looks like.
I've even got the shading here,
and I remember that there were
five of these.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't see it yet, but there's
not five of anything on them.
-Think there's five of those.
-Okay.
-And, oh, man. I did have fun.
I did have fun with these.
-I don't know.
-This is it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you know what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know what? Not half bad.
Oh, my God. Paula Pell!
-I'm sorry!
It's not -- It's a little guy!
[ Laughter ]
-We're so happy to have you
here.
We're so happy that "Girls5eva"
is coming back,
and thank you so much.
I know it's not ideal
when Fred's here,
but you toughed it out.
-[ Laughs ] I love you.
Thank you.
-Paula Pell, everybody.
Season three of "Girls5eva" is
coming to Netflix
later this year.
We'll be right back with
Chef Michael Solomonov.